schnee im weltraum erstmals schneegrenze
in einer protoplanetaren scheibe
entdeckt jetzt bei clixoom science
fiction mit hilfe des atacama large
millimeter array soder kurz alma haben
wissenschaftler erstmals die
schneegrenze von wasser innerhalb eines
jungen planetensystems analysieren
können schnee im weltraum mal kurz zur
erklärung ohne den einfluss der energie
eines sterns also der wärme gefrieren
gase und wasser im weltraum zu als diese
grenze also die schneegrenze diese
eisgrenze ist normalerweise nicht
sichtbar da sie sich sehr nah an einem
stern befindet so ungefähr drei
astronomische einheiten entfernt zur
erinnerung eine astronomische einer
entspricht 149 milliarden 597 millionen
78.700 metern das ist ungefähr der
mittlere abstand zwischen sonne und erde
durch das starke licht des sterns wird
aber die schneegrenze überstrahlt und
kann nicht abgebildet werden
wissenschaftler haben jetzt bei der
untersuchung des sterns v 8 8 3 orion
ist diese grenze eher zufällig
beobachten können der stern befindet
sich rund 1350 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt und eigentlich haben die
forscher nach lücken in dessen
protoplanetaren scheibe gesucht die
besteht aus staub und gasen die sich um
den stern herum legen sich mit drehen
und aus denen später planeten entstehen
können die astronomen der universität
diego portale sind santiago de chile
konnten dann allerdings die lücken nicht
ausfindig machen
zitat wir haben nichts davon gesehen
stattdessen fanden wir etwas in einer
entfernung von 40 astronomischen
einheiten vom stern das wie ein ring
aussah so luca scassa einer der forscher
weiter die temperatur an dieser grenze
passt besser zur wasser schneegrenze als
zur schneegrenze von jedem anderen
flüchtigen bestandteile protoplanetaren
scheiben zitat ende
die eigenschaften dieses rings konnten
sie also denen der schneegrenze vom
wasser zu ordnen
allerdings war die entfernung zum stern
eine distanz die der vom pluto zur sonne
entspricht also viel zu hoch eigentlich
die forscher erklären sich diesen
außergewöhnlichen fund mit den
eigenschaften des sterns v 8 8 3 orion
ist dieser stößt öfter große energie
impulse aus wobei sich seine helligkeit
stark vergrößert dabei schafft er es
eine 400 mal so große leuchtkraft zu
entwickeln
wie die sonne ist aber nur 30
sonnenmassen größer als diese durch den
erhöhten ausstoß einer energie steigt
die temperatur um den stern und in der
plot protoplanetaren scheibe dadurch
verschiebt sich die grenze in der es so
kalt ist das wasser zu eis wird merklich
das material innerhalb der
protoplanetaren scheibe gefriert bei
diesem stern eben erst in einer
entfernung von 40 statt drei
astronomischen einheiten dank dieser
zufalls entdeckung konnten die
wissenschaftler nun zum ersten mal die
schneegrenze von wasser innerhalb einer
protoplanetaren scheibe abbilden 2013
war schon mal ähnliches geglückt damals
wurde die schneegrenze von
kohlenstoffmonoxid um den stern tw
hydrae beobachtet der von uns 175
lichtjahre entfernt ist die erkenntnisse
über die schnee grenzen verschiedener
stoffe können aufschluss über die
entstehung von planeten geben jetzt
wissen die forscher dass energie
eruption diese grenzen stark verschieben
können
da die forschung davon ausgeht dass die
ausbrüche bei jungen stern ganz normal
sind müssen die verschiebung mit
eingeplant werden wenn man sich gedanken
über die entstehung von planeten machen
will wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann würde ich mich über so was freuen
einen daumen nach oben und natürlich ein
kostenloses abo einfach dafür hier
klicken
und was glaubt ihr werden wir noch über
die entstehung von planeten lernen
können gibt es theorien die sich bald
als wahr oder falsch herausstellen
könnten ich bin auf eure kommentare
gespannt und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran